Speaker 1: All right, let's speak to a few
more people via The David Pakman Show discord,
which you can find at David Pakman dotcom
slash discord. It is a great discord. I highly,
highly recommend it. Let's go next to Will from
L.A. now. Is that Los Angeles or Louisiana?
Speaker 3: It's Los Angeles.
Speaker 1: All right, welcome.
Speaker 3: How are you doing so I'm sorry if
this has already been brought up before, but
curious about your thoughts on this Gabby Petito
thing, obviously it's a huge story. But then
on one side, you hear a lot of people kind of
irritated that a lot of black and indigenous
and Hispanic people aren't getting the
same sort of visibility for their case.
I'm just curious what your thoughts on
that are. I mean, I personally think it's
really tough to to demean this poor girl's
existence, to demean her own individual case
by complaining about maybe other cases that
don't get the same sort of coverage. And I'm just
curious what your what your thoughts on that are.
Speaker 1: Yes. So there's really three stories
here. And we talked about this on a
bonus show earlier this week. So first,
there's just the facts of the Gabby Petito story.
As of this moment, her her fiance, Brian Landry,
is missing. There's speculation as to his
involvement in her disappearance and subsequent
death, et cetera, et cetera. So there's the facts
of that story and the way that it's been reported.
These stories, they do really well, particularly
for local news stations, like I think there's a
station in Tampa that has just done really well
covering every aspect of this. And so it's sort
of like a car chase. Fox News starts covering
the car chase, et cetera. So there's that and
the salacious nature of the initial story. Then
you started to see commentaries from like Joy Read
on MSNBC and some other places saying, hey, you
know what, this is missing white girl syndrome.
If this was a black woman, if this was an
indigenous woman or whatever, you would not be
seeing this amount of coverage. Newsweek even had
an article where they said, hey, you know what?
Gabby Petito went missing in Wyoming over the last
decade. Four hundred sixty six indigenous women
have gone missing in Wyoming. None of them got
this amount of coverage. I think to some degree
that's true. I also think it's a combination
of factors. It's pretty 22 year old white girl,
some social media notoriety, a 90 minute or
hour long police stop body cam video that
adds to the mystique and it adds to the story the
fiancee goes missing. You know, I think that there
are more aspects to it, but I think to some degree
there is a difference in coverage based on the
identity of the of the victim. And then the third
story is many of the media outlets criticizing
the coverage, saying when it's a black woman or
an indigenous woman, we don't get the coverage.
They also never covered the missing black or
indigenous women, which is like the third layer,
which is they are making headlines, talking about
the disparity, but they contributed to that very
same disparity. You know what I'm saying?
Speaker 3: Well,
I totally agree with that point. Absolutely.
Speaker 1: So in terms of not demeaning this,
what happened to Gabby Petito? I'm with you.
Like her case is no less tragic because of
these other media stories, that it's sort of like
running through a cancer fundraiser and saying,
what about AIDS? Right. Like, I get that it's
still important to understand why certain
stories get more coverage than others, though.
Speaker 3: Absolutely. It really is important to
understand and and I feel for for anybody that
goes missing, it doesn't matter. They're their
gender, race or anything. Of course, it's
terrible. And I just I hope that there's more
light that is shined on those people, you know,
on on anybody that goes missing. And I also hope
for some sort of healing for, you know, Gabby's
Gabby's family and and people who loved her. And,
yeah, it's just it's terrible all around
anybody who goes missing. But thank
you so much for your time, David. I really
appreciate you. Big fan of the show. Thanks.
Speaker 1: Will Will from L.A. very much.
Appreciate the call. And a good topic. I mean,
there's a lot of different stories
there. That's that's the reality.